tu
[Musica]
Wow
Wow Wow Wow si grazie
bueno um break the  box questo è
un
po' quello di cui parlerò oggi e voglio spiegarvi un po' cosa intendo per rompere la scatola
quindi sono cresciuto in una casa dove i miei genitori
ci hanno sempre dato molta libertà
ci ha incoraggiato a fare ciò che amiamo fare
ciò che ci appassiona molto, quindi
non ho mai avuto pressioni su di me per
seguire i modi di vita convenzionali di
cui sono davvero felice, quindi è un po'
come se fossi ancora un bambino che gioca  musica che
suona il Box come una scimmietta
qui sul palco per voi ragazzi è uno
scherzo dovreste ridere ora quindi comunque in
questa lunga storia sono cresciuto in Sud
Africa poi mi sono trasferito a Londra quando avevo
18 anni e volevo studiare  toglierò
questo e la pelliccia perché non è una pelliccia per
favore non uccidermi ma mi sono trasferito
a Londra quando avevo 18 anni e volevo davvero
per studiare musica in una
scuola jazz molto importante c'era solo un problema,
non avevo soldi per andare a studiare in questa
scuola e per di più dovevo anche
fare soldi per mantenermi e
aiutare i miei genitori hanno anche appena
sono immigrato a Londra, quindi ho dovuto
iniziare a suonare per strada suonando per strada
Non riuscivo a trovare un lavoro in questa
fase perché avrei dovuto
dipendere dai miei genitori, quindi non ero
legalmente autorizzato a svolgere normali
lavori e lavori regolari  e in realtà sono davvero
felice di dire che non l'ho mai fatto non ho mai
lavorato per nessuno in vita mia intendo
ovviamente vengo assunto per fare un lavoro
ma sono sempre stato il capo di me stesso
ed è qualcosa che sono molto  contento
e deriva dal fatto che nella mia vita ho
sempre applicato il principio del break in
the box e credo che sia
la chiave per liberare ciò che sei destinato
a fare e ciò che ami fare ed è allora
che tu  Cambierà davvero il
mondo, cambierà la tua stessa vita e
ispirerà le altre persone a farlo  la stessa
cosa e fare le cose che
dovrebbero fare comunque così ho iniziato a
suonare per strada per me era un po'
una scatola da rompere venendo dal Sud
Africa suonando per strada devi
solo sistemarti nel mezzo  dal nulla
molto spaventoso ho iniziato con un sassofono
poi ho incontrato un chitarrista e
ho fatto un duetto cantavo suonava
la chitarra e circa un anno dopo ogni
giorno cantava per le strade di Londra
imparando e così via ho ottenuto
molto  di dolore alle corde vocali, quindi ho
dovuto fare qualcosa al riguardo e questo è stato
quando mi è stato presentato il Box the
Cajon, che è quello che suono qui
oggi per voi ragazzi, che è anche uno
dei grandi motivi per cui sono su  in questa fase
e perché sto facendo quello che amo fare il
chitarrista con cui stavo suonando era anche
molto interessato al flamenco e alla musica latina
e ho avuto molta esposizione a
quella fase, il che è stato davvero fantastico,
non ho mai avuto quell'opportunità in  Sud
Africa e mi ha parlato di questa scatola una
scatola come un dr  um kit in una scatola all'inizio
ho riso di lui e ho pensato che stesse
scherzando, ma era serio, quindi si trattava
di quando avevo 19 anni circa 10 anni fa,
poi mi sono presentato al Cajon, quindi ha
comprato una casa dalla Spagna e io  sono stato
gettato nel profondo con questo con
questa scatola ho dovuto iniziare a suonare
per strada su uno strumento di cui
non avevo mai sentito parlare in vita mia e in
quel momento nessuno suonava il Cajon
a Londra era molto molto nuovo era
ancora usato principalmente nella musica del flamenco
e non avevo nemmeno un insegnante a Londra, quindi
dovevo solo capirlo da
solo, quindi ancora un'altra scatola qualcosa di
molto scomodo che dovevo
rompere ma di solito è quando sei davvero in una situazione
situazione scomoda in cui si
finisce per trovare la soluzione per
qualcosa che in realtà è qualcosa
che rompe qualcosa di più grande
se non foste stati in quella
posizione scomoda se voi ragazzi sapete cosa voglio dire
sono sicuro che tutti voi conoscete molto
bene questo concetto quindi  praticamente qualche
anno dopo ho aggiunto alcuni video su
YouTube nella speranza di aiutare qualcun
altro che si è trovato nella stessa
situazione in cui avrebbe potuto imparare alcune
lezioni da me Non sapevo molto
del mondo online YouTube era molto nuovo quindi
è stata una mia sorpresa che le persone abbiano
reagito davvero bene, ho molti follower
, è ancora in crescita il fatto
che oggi vedo oltre 70.000 iscritti
sul mio canale, il che è davvero fantastico,
ho il più grande canale YouTube Cajon,
sì è davvero bello ed è  ancora in
crescita e ho intenzione di tirare fuori un DVD
metodo moderno per il Cajon, si spera che lo
introduca nelle scuole e nei
sistemi educativi che vorrebbero avere un
metodo formalizzato per il Cajon nel
nostro mondo occidentale perché c'è molto
nei luoghi in cui è arrivato
di cui parleremo tra un
po', ma non c'è molto nel
mondo occidentale, quindi come puoi vedere per
tutta la mia vita ho sempre
trovato un modo per fare qualcosa di diverso
t  han altre persone e mi ha portato
a un punto in cui sto facendo esattamente quello
che voglio fare infatti se fossi un bambino ora
per guardarmi oggi sarei abbastanza
felice Non mi sto vantando di me stesso ma
semplicemente felice  con dove mi trovo perché sono in
grado di suonare la mia musica e fare ciò che
amo fare e condividere con le persone qualcosa di
eccitante e interessante in un modo molto strano
che non avrei mai pensato sarebbe
successo comunque sono passati alcuni anni l'
anno scorso il mondo  ho visto il lancio del primo
clacson per auto ibrida e ho avuto il grande onore di
aver ricevuto un'e-mail da loro mi hanno chiesto
di essere l'artista internazionale per questo
prodotto che è stato davvero fantastico perché
questo è il nuovo movimento e dove
hanno aggiunto suoni elettronici su
il Cajon e andando ancora oltre e
poi anche l'anno scorso è
successo questo video virale che è stato anche
un momento piuttosto fuori dagli schemi ed è divertente
come un momento in cui ti lasci andare
e tiri fuori la passione che
sei così felice di  finisce per
farti ottenere 70 milioni di visualizzazioni in cinque
giorni, è piuttosto pazzesco
quindi sì, è praticamente dove siamo
ora e ora ho TEDx Sono sul
palco TEDx che è anche un'altra scatola così
mentre sto parlando  a te sul rompere una
scatola Sto rompendo una scatola e quattro anni
fa ho guardato il mio primo video TEDx e
ho pensato che lo avrei fatto un giorno
sarò su un palco TEDx quindi oggi è
il giorno quindi è sì grazie  tutto
bene ma voglio spiegarvi ragazzi
che non sono troppo lungo non troppo tempo non siamo
ancora alla fine ok tutto vi spiego
ragazzi un po' del concetto di
rompere la scatola semplicemente usando un
vero  scatola per spiegartelo
ora il Cajon stesso Non so
quanti di voi lo sappiano ma sta ancora
crescendo è molto nuovo ma vediamo un mondo in
cui l'80% del nostro lavoro circa l'80% delle
vendite di percussioni sono contro ogni  il negozio in
cui vai ha dei coni e nel negozio
intendo non tutti ma in genere
migliaia di persone stanno iniziando a suonare
musi  c per la prima volta o tornare
alla musica grazie al Cajon per la
sua semplicità perché è qualcosa
che è gratuito e facile da suonare
e ovviamente abbiamo milioni di sterline
e aziende e persone che ci guadagnano anche molti
soldi, quindi è  crea
molti posti di lavoro crea un grande mercato per le
persone e voglio riportarti
dove tutto ha avuto inizio e solo
per mostrarti come una persona che
pensa fuori dagli schemi o vede più
di una semplice scatola potrebbe effettivamente trasformarsi
le cose a testa in giù così bene che qualcuno
come me può essere sul palco proprio qui
oggi per questo motivo, quindi
vi porterò indietro ragazzi proprio dove è iniziato
il cajon è nato nella loro stanza in
Sud America, quindi molte persone non lo fanno  Non lo
so, ma è nato in Perù e
il modo in cui è nato è stato davvero
bello, era anche un po' una cosa fondamentalmente
quando gli spagnoli colonizzarono il
Perù e in qualche modo proibirono i tamburi degli
schiavi africani in Perù come un modo per  rompere i
loro s  piriti per opprimerli di nuovo mettili
in una scatola e così questi ragazzi sono stati
trovati tutti i nostri tamburi sono spariti non possiamo
esprimere la nostra anima voglio dire che vieni
dall'Africa quei palchi tutto quello che avevi era la tua
musica e quindi per farla breve
questi ragazzi hanno finito per giocare su semplici
scatole che usavano su cui stavano
lavorando per imballare pesce, frutta e
verdura nelle scatole, quindi è così che
il cono è nato proprio per
resistere a qualcuno che
vuole opprimerti e mettere  voi in una scatola quindi
vi mostrerò il
cajon peruviano perché è leggermente diverso
da quello che sto suonando in questo momento va bene
ehi questo è un cajon peruviano voglio dire che è
un po' piccolo ho avuto un bagaglio limitato
oggi quindi  Voglio dire ieri da portare
sul volo ma sono
ragionevolmente più grandi hanno circa quelle
dimensioni ma questo è più piccolo ma
ti darà una buona idea di
come suona ed è solo una scatola  ok
è una scatola vuota con un piccolo foro nella
parte posteriore  davvero fantastico davvero facile puoi
immaginare che c'erano un sacco di pesciolini
qui e dopo la tua lunga giornata di lavoro
questo è ciò che è uscito ed è così che
è nato praticamente proprio da quello e
poi il cajon ha avuto il suo prossimo viaggio
che è stato il Kahuna  seduto su di
esso è andato in Spagna per la
musica di flamenco c'era un grande chitarrista chiamato
Paco de Lucia il capo alcune persone avrebbero
discusso che è andato a fare un
concerto in Perù e qualcuno gli ha dato un
mega Cajon perché un cajon peruviano
perché un  pochi anni dopo questo è diventato
l'orgoglio nazionale del Perù, quindi se vai
in Perù oggi sono molto orgogliosi del
loro Cajon peruviano fa parte
dell'intera società è un enorme Festival internazionale del
Cajon Ci sono stato l'anno scorso
ed è stato fantastico fare alcuni seminari
ed è semplicemente bello vedere 5.000
persone riunirsi fuori ognuna
con il Cajon e tutti suonare
insieme e penso che ci riporti anche
al punto in cui dovremmo condividere la
musica con la comunità  e non si tratta
solo del solista in questa pagina,
che è qualcosa che abbiamo iniziato ad
accettare di cosa tratta la musica nel nostro
mondo occidentale, ma dimentichiamo che la
musica riguarda la comunità, ogni tamburo suona la sua
parte nell'insieme del brano musicale
e credo che tutti
dovrebbero fare musica è una
lingua internazionale ce l'abbiamo dentro vogliamo
tirarla fuori e lo facevamo ma
ora ci sediamo a casa e guardiamo la TV invece
di sederci attorno al fuoco a
fare musica e ritmi  insieme, quindi
il tono sta riportando molto di questo
nel mondo, tutto bene tornando
al flamenco Cajon qui andiamo a
cambiare è un po' più strano del
mio vestitino così è stato portato in Spagna
da questo chitarrista di flamenco hanno aggiunto le
corde sul davanti  tavola quindi ci sono
due corde di chitarra su questo lato due
corde di chitarra sul lato contro il
legno per renderlo più adatto
alla musica flamenco e questo è nato
[Musica]
no no quindi grazie mille per
questo  prima che il Cajon fosse aggiunto
al flusso della musica del flamenco,
il vero ritmo era claps e
i polimeri dei piedi, quindi questo è stato
davvero automaticamente accettato nella
musica del flamenco e poi da lì il
Cajon si è avventurato dall'Europa perché
era in Europa  più accessibile e
poiché suonava molto come una batteria,
grancassa, rullante, abbiamo iniziato a
vederla yo yeah perchè il mio milkshake porta tutti
i ragazzi in cortile hai dannatamente ragione
ragazza è meglio della tua
yeah hey cosa farai yeah perchè  sono
felice mi sento felice di avere il sole in
una borsa sono inutile ma non per molto il
futuro è tempo che tutto si o sballi
in palestra pompalo il tuo perché i tuoi
piedi calpestano e la marmellata sta pompando guarda
qui il terreno sta saltando così puoi
vedere come molte di queste cose sono come
se fosse davvero il bellissimo punto focale
grazie mille ok ok
quindi finirò con questo molto
molto rapidamente ci sono state aggiunte delle
cose ovviamente io  T  vecchi
ragazzi dell'elettronica che è stata aggiunta anche al
Cajon, il che ora significa che sono in grado
di fare altre cose sul Cajon
che non potrei solo
quindi sto suonando a qualcuno su questo o
potete andare davvero  pesante e fallo
bene, quindi fondamentalmente per correre
tutto il mio discorso rompi la scatola nella tua
stessa vita e vedrai alcune
cose incredibili accadere non solo nella tua stessa vita
ma per le altre persone intorno a te e
potresti fare un enorme enorme  differenza nella
tua vita per tutti gli altri quindi
grazie mille per aver guardato la visione grazie
a TEDx grazie ragazzi
[Applausi]
[Musica]
voi